thank you very much chair
we have just commemorated the horrors of
Rana Plaza the hundreds of victims
many of whom had not wanted to go into
the building but were threatened and
made to pay with their lives
a disaster that tragically could have
been avoided
Rana Plaza is not the only disaster
linked to corporate greed
are the only disaster linked to
companies misbehaving and turning a
blind eye
Syed a cartoon died last December and in
her lifetime never had justice for her
son who died in a burning clothing
Factory in Bangladesh
fire escapes were blocked the factory in
question made genes for a known German
brand
or Rosita te Quarry Veronica manimbu who
are still fighting for justice after
their homes were destroyed by a palm oil
company in West Pap were financed with
European money
Injustice impunity that makes your
stomach turn
these are examples that show the need
for rules on responsible business
because we are talking about daily
occurrences of injuries pollution
corruption on the other side of the
world as well as in Europe
and tragically nobody is ever to blame
everybody points to someone else
companies say it wasn't them it was
their supplier they didn't know low
prices are very welcome
responsibility is not
but we're not talking about all
companies let's be very clear about that
many companies and sectors have taken
action voluntarily
especially after Rana Plaza
and yet it hasn't been enough for True
change action has been too patchy and
there's often too little Justice for
victims
so for victims the case for this law is
very very clear but for businesses this
law is a vital importance also why
because they need certainty about what
to do as well as the certainty that
their competitors are doing the same
as for consumers they in themselves
cannot change the world even if it were
possible for people to check every
company and every label that won't make
enough of a difference and that's why
we're making a law on what responsible
business means
what we have before us is a political
agreement that I am very proud of
it was painstakingly negotiated over
three years
and it tries to take into account every
difficulty that was raised by everyone
who will be affected by this law workers
and companies alike
it has always been my aim to negotiate a
position with cross-party support in
this house which is proportionate and
workable for business and effective and
accessible for victims why because this
legislation is too important for us not
to deliver
this is about what kind of Europe you
want to live in and what we as Europeans
value it's about what kind of trade we
want in the future how we see
globalization and about defining our
relationship with China
it's about serious action on
sustainability and climate and if we
don't take a firm stand in Europe then
who will our task in a United Parliament
is to set Global standards as we have
done in the past
I think that's a good idea
because it is not true you and I know
that we can't change the world so it's
individuals the strongest shoulders have
to bear the heaviest burden and a better
world starts with better companies
that's better for everybody who's
standing in a shop and wondering how
which clothes they should buy because
there should be an obligation people
have to take this seriously those
companies
will be supported if we adopt these
rules but the companies who ignore the
rules and abuse the situation have to be
stopped in their path we can see that
the thousands of people who died workers
in in Qatar during the World Cup
building stadia and
we know that the natural reserves such
as in Indonesia their Forest being
pulled down to build Pipelines
so we have to have responsible companies
and to do that we have to have European
legislation
many companies are asking themselves for
clearer rules but should apply across
Europe
at the moment this is falling on deaf
ears however in in the right to the
right in this parliament are talking
about all sorts of right of
establishment and the red tape that that
companies have to put up with
but
you know there are other people who are
suffering and there are other ways of
addressing this and I think political
games is really not where we should be
now let us assume political
responsibility tomorrow as Europeans as
a European Parliament let us take a
serious step tomorrow for a more
sustainable and a fairer world thank you
thank you very much
now turn into Portuguese
poised
so having heard from the rapporteur
we now move on to the the speakers
representing the Committees
that were a part of this process and
we'll start with the Foreign Affairs
committee
Mr glucksman has the floor
ladies and gentlemen
this is a pregnancy
test and I found a letter in here it was
a Chinese worker asking for help
someone producing something that is then
sold in a French chemist so this is the
irresponsible pyramid of globalization a
world without rules where those who hold
the most power also have the least
responsibility Zara Nike and Sheen
Chine and
the moment has come to make sure that
multinational companies are held
accountable we're talking about human
rights violations in the value chain the
time has come to make sure they stop
hiding behind their supplier
subcontractor or Branch this due
diligence
Act is extremely important to try and
water it down or to reject it flies in
the face of our principles and our
interests each and every one of us
ladies and gentlemen will have to pay
for this when it comes to the vote thank
you
thank you very much the next speaker on
behalf of the international trade
committee the intercommittee is Barry
Andrews dear colleagues
all companies carry out due diligence on
their supply chains
but only insofar as it impacts the
operations of their own company
what makes this proposal radical is that
for the first time companies will be
mandated to carry out due diligence on
the supply chain as it affects the
planet as it affects human rights abuses
this has been an extremely divisive text
but I want to set the record straight
contrary to what you might hear from
this in this hemicycle today smes are
excluded from The Proposal contrary to
what you might hear today this is not a
regulatory burden there are already
supply chain laws in EU member states so
this is deregulatory in effect by
creating a Level Playing Field it is
also aligned with the corporate
sustainability reporting directive and
therefore companies not only know what
they have to report but they also know
what they have to do so this provides
businesses with the opportunity to take
advantage of the European green deal it
also gives citizens for the first time a
very clear choice it takes human rights
and environmental degradation out of our
shopping baskets thank you very much
six
[Applause]
of econ
omy
president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen
money moves the world a world in which
companies are hardly impressed
by
underemployed competition authorities in
countries or complaints before the
courts that are very difficult to prove
no in this world all they're scared of
is that people turn the tap off to stop
their flow of money if people start
complaining about human rights and the
environment in their supply chains
this is the possibility that exists for
Council
but the right doesn't want to close this
tap and the council doesn't either
people who've made big profits ladies
and gentlemen has the damn duty to make
sure that these profits go to protect
human rights and the environment so the
people who are absent the right I can
just appeal to them come back to the
good side it is not too late yet
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much and now on behalf of
the employment and social Affairs
committee
has the floor
Echo dots
I hope that the European Parliament
tomorrow will assume its responsibility
it's a great shame to see over the
recent days that certain colleagues most
notably from the right in this chamber
have been trying to find a coalition to
table amendments that goes completely
contrary to the essence of this new and
important piece of legislation I'd like
to thank the rapporteur a very good job
that's been done
it's uh no excuse that the ample
committee wanted to go a lot further and
if I had a say in this then there would
have been a question of responsibility
for all companies regardless of their
size when it comes to human rights in
the environment it's a good deal because
it doesn't matter how big the
administrative pressure is human rights
cannot be subjugated but it's no time to
be dogmatic we need to push on through
we need to finally give companies the
possibility to assume International
responsibility pursuant to the oecd
guidelines we're going to push on with
this
because we want to look at products that
are made from Forced labor they have to
be removed from our markets economy is
driven by people made by people so first
and foremost that is what we're doing
this for as well for people thank you
thank you very much the next speaker on
behalf of the environment committee is
timofulkin
president
thank you very much commissioner thank
you for being here ladies and gentlemen
what right do we have in the European
Union consume products that are produced
in parts of the world where human rights
are being abused the environment is
being destroyed or actually people are
being exploited what right do we have to
do that we don't have a right to do that
at all hence it is very
it is essential that we have a strong
supply chain law that applies not just
to the EU and the stops at its borders
but it has Global application and with
this csdd that we'll be looking at
adopting tomorrow have an opportunity to
make sure we're not using double
standards but we are in fact making sure
that human rights and environmental
standards are applied across the world
in the same way and I certainly hope
that EPP will agree to this law tomorrow
and we're not adopt a compromise that
we'll make sure that human rights and
invite the environment would not be
protected there should be fair uh a fair
approach for everybody concerned
including the companies the environment
human rights and the workers and that's
why we have to send this common signal
tomorrow thank you
thank you very much I now like to pass
the floor to the European commission
namely to today horrendous commissioner
you have the floor
thank you very much president ladies and
gentlemen members of the European
Parliament I'm particularly happy to be
having this debate with you today on the
draft report of your European Parliament
on corporate sustainability due
diligence the commission welcomes the
work that's been done by the legal
Affairs committee as well as the
interest of the European Parliament in
the legislative proposal that was
presented by the Commission in February
of last year
which is a common political priority I
would like in particular to express my
thanks to the reporter Madame Lowe
volters as well as the shadow reporters
for this file we've had the opportunity
on numerous occasions throughout the
whole of this process to have exchanges
of use in a particularly constructive
atmosphere we share the ambition to have
cross-cutting legislative action at
European Union level so that we can
genuinely implement the goals of the EU
in terms of the transition to a fairer
more sustainable approach towards
company law opportunity for the union
this legislation can have an important
impact on the way companies operate
globally
it can lead to the development of new
more sustainable business models by
large companies operating in the
European Union Market
many stakeholders are asking for this
consumers investors employees and The
Wider public as well as many companies
themselves
indeed this is an initiative where we
want companies to be on board
we are ready to continue to work
together with them to make due diligence
a reality on the ground
in order to achieve our goals we
proposed harmonize and mandatory rules
on corporate due diligence and directors
duties
existing International recommendations
and voluntary schemes have played an
important role so far
but they have not been sufficient to
lead to the necessary changes and to
ensure a Level Playing Field throughout
the whole economy
with this proposal we can indeed offer
leg of certainty and a Level Playing
Field for companies across the European
Union
support for smes better access to
finance and guidance to facilitate the
transition
this proposal aims to support companies
in winning their business in a way that
effectively address possible negative
impacts on human rights and the
environment throughout their value
chains
a review of more than 2 000 studies
shows that integrating human rights and
Environmental Protection into business
operations leads to competitive
advantages in all sectors of the economy
and to more innovation
so our main objective is to ensure that
long-term perspectives and
sustainability factors are better
integrated in corporate strategies and
decision making
therefore in all view a clarification of
the director's duty of care is also
useful
the duty of care of directors is already
present in all the legal systems of all
member states
The commission's Proposal does not set a
new duty of care but only clarifies
duties already present in national law
to make sure that directors are
empowered to act also with regard to the
long term
it is important to make sure that
sustainability considerations are taken
into account in the major decisions of
large companies
The Proposal does not change the
existing enforcement regime in this
regard
only shareholders would be able to hold
directors to account
as regards climate change
in all proposal we provided for a
special regime that would require large
companies to adopt a climate transition
plan to ensure that their business
modeling strategy are compatible with
the objective to limit global warning
warming to 1.5 in line with the Paris
agreement the commission change to be
covered by the whole due diligence
regime
and of course the commission did not
propose sorry to a change to be covered
by the whole due diligence regime so
there are two systems one with the
judicials process for harms to the
environment and violation human rights
and a transition plan for climate ladies
and gentlemen
the commission proposed that the new
rules apply only to large companies
which have the capacity to implement the
measures needed and notably to
scrutinize their value chains smes don't
fall under the scope of the proposed
directive and words therefore be
excluded of the administrative and civil
liability regimes contemplated in terms
of enforcement
to limit the impact of this proposal on
smes across value chains the commission
also proposed to provide them with
Technical and financial support notably
SME should benefit from specific
guidance and tools
hit a nutshell or approach when
designing the proposal has therefore
been Guided by the need to ensure
proportionality being mindful of impacts
on competitiveness while at the same
time ensuring that we trigger a solid
change on more sustainable value chains
I would like to conclude by pressing
again your work and commitment on this
file with this report we are making
further progress in this important field
it is good a good indicator that we
should be able to reach a final
agreement soon I'm now looking forward
to the upcoming try logs I thank you of
course for your attention and if it's
possible to go further tomorrow we'll
start very fast the dialogue but before
that I will now listen with interest to
your for interventions thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much commissioner
we'll now hear from
two further committees first of all the
development committee Yolanda basso has
the floor
thank you president
would you to vote on a piece of
legislation that is breaking new ground
so that companies will be forced to take
into account human rights and the
environment it shouldn't really be
breaking you ground in the 21st century
companies that work in developing
countries have to respect human rights
the environment and the principle of the
rule of law especially if we are to
achieve the goals for the UN
2030. it's not the size of the company
it's the size of the damage that is done
by the company that is essential
so more companies should be covered by
this legislation the trade unions
influences of central importance to
strengthen this legislation we need more
efficient more effective and
proportionate sanctions for companies
who
violate human rights and damage the
environment now it is important that we
get this done and dusted to generate a
future in which human rights and the
environment are protected and those who
abuse that are held to account for their
actions thank you president
[Applause]
on behalf of the internal Market
Committee is Madame Clune and we need to
support and to enable business to act
more sustainably and responsibly
in their Global and their EU activities
and this proposal is a step towards
doing that while also bringing legal
certainty and a Level Playing Field when
compared to the existing situation where
there's a varying degree of approaches
taken across the member states products
and services that are the result of
Human Rights and environmental
violations should not be allowed on the
European market the EU is capable of
setting high standards and having a
strong influence on Global Supply chains
and we can use this influence to address
human rights violations and breaches of
Social and environmental standards and I
was concerned that the proposed
directive took the minimum harmonization
approach because it leaves rooms for
member states to impose diverging
obligations from those in this directive
that may actually undermine legal
certainty and that creation of that
Level Playing Field so the improved text
with a dedicated article to fully
harmonize the provision of this
directive during its transportation and
therefore after there will be a revision
of six years to assess whether it should
be turned into a regular regulation is
an improvement and it will lead to an
increase of harmonization and cross
cross-border cooperation thank you
thank you very much now let's move on to
the speakers on behalf of the political
groups starting with the EPP
axelvoss has the floor
president commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
especially from the jury working group I
would like to express a vote of thanks
to
the cooperation we had that showed
always respect to each other even if we
had differing opinions we managed to
achieve compromises
this is a very political topic even
within the Epp and this is why it hasn't
been straightforward for us
we've reached a stage now where we are
saying we have to look at red tape we
have to stop red tape for companies and
of course especially for smaller
medium-sized Enterprises
and in doing this we have to take into
account reality the reality we see at
the moment be it covered be it the
Russian war of aggression be it the
expansion of China and this is why it's
a very difficult environment to move in
and originally
I would have hoped that the commission
had come up with a better proposal that
was more balanced
What We Lay store by is full
harmonization
companies need to have a single Market
within which they can work
rather than leaving this up to the
member state so I would have hoped for a
bit more ambition a bit more Innovative
approach to pushing this forward
although what we have may be enough the
sectoral initiatives that we've agreed
on is where I Harbor hopes that at least
we'll can see more harmonization coming
down the road what's important for me is
the risk-based approach whereby we can
focus on those areas or those parts of
the value chain or supply chain where
risks genuinely exist rather than just
doing something blindly
of course what's always important for us
is to look at red tape and keep that as
to a minimum and I still believe that if
we were to try and coddle the companies
more and they feel obliged to achieve
the goals that would be a better
approach rather than impose
goals on them but the compromises are
there I think it provides a good basis
on which to work not everything on the
table is something that I'm happy with
or my group is happy with and I hope
that maybe we can get a few improvements
through the try log process to help
companies and to reduce red tape thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much on behalf of the s d
group the next speaker is Vice President
madame marigna
thank you thank you very much president
commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
I think you've put a lot of effort into
this file
at
eucsdd constitutes a unique opportunity
an opportunity to explain to companies
exactly what the rules we expect of them
to achieve and what is feasible for them
it's an opportunity to help consumers so
that they are relieved of the obligation
if they're in the supermarket or in a
shop
that they don't know which product they
can buy with a clear conscience it's a
unique opportunity to make sure that
each and every product on available in
our internal Market is produced in
harmony with human rights in the
environment for the csdd it's a question
of transparency it's a question of
including the trade unions and the ngos
it's about the respect of Human Rights
and social rights it's about protecting
the environment
and we cannot afford
to miss this unique opportunity
[Applause]
on behalf of the renew group the next
speaker is Adrian Vasquez
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
a little bit over one month ago we had
the tragic anniversary of the 10 years
of the Rana Plaza collapse that claimed
the lives of more than 1 100 people and
injured 2500 people we knew that we
could have avoided and we should have
avoided that
people spotted cracks structural cracks
and they shouldn't have let the workers
go back the next day this strategy is
even more serious but it should be
important for us to make sure that we
pass new laws that give rights to
workers and protects our planet tomorrow
we're going to be voting on the csdd
legislation that makes sure that
Economic Development and social progress
are more compatible with protecting
individual rights and and the
environment this is a balanced text it's
taken hours and hours of negotiations to
Cobble it together and it's balanced
because we've got a freedom economic
freedom and growth uh with
responsibility and accountability
because one without the other is unfair
and the other way around it would be
unbearable so that is why I call an
all-political groups to support this
director is going to be a milestone a
landmark in this parliament's term but
also in the future for the future of the
EU
let us be firm so no one can say that
this house didn't do everything it could
to make it possible thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you green
the president commissioner colleagues
since the adoption of the U.N guiding
principles on business and human rights
over 10 years ago many businesses have
worked hard to ensure that their
activities are not linked to human
rights violations or environmental
destruction European consumers and
investors expect nothing less
nevertheless too many companies still
act as Free Riders
and gain unfair competitive Advantage
from irresponsible business activity the
agreement that has now been reached in
the legal Affairs committee offers to
level the playing field it is a balanced
compromise well aligned with widely
accepted International standards
a key feature is access to Justice
without access to Justice the directive
would end up as a paper tiger
victims of Human Rights abuse is linked
to corporate activities must have the
right to seek Justice and to hold
companies accountable for dodging their
obligations
now the world is keenly watching what we
decide here tomorrow yet another
Brussels moment could be at hand
as one of the world's largest markets
the EU can be a force for good in
clearly defining the responsibilities of
companies to respect human rights and
protect the environment
it should be noted that many developing
countries producing Goods designed for
the EU Market will need support in
adapting to this legislation luckily the
EU has several Avenues available ranging
from development cooperation to
Partnerships and integrating responsible
business conduct into different
instruments and dialogues this
legislation is not about soothing the
conscience of European consumers it is
about promoting the core values of our
Union and responding effectively to
Global Environmental and human rights
challenges we must now seize this
opportunity to Leverage The Power of
business to strengthen the respect for
human rights and to fight environmental
destruction throughout the world thank
you very much
[Music]
foreign
ers
Mr bushetti
thank you very much president
commissioner rapporte we really are
seeing an idea of common sense with the
csdd violations of human rights police
and judges should be judging them not by
putting more burdens and cost on
companies the only consequence of this
is that the companies and workers of
Europe are going to be poorer less
competitive and now we've got European
companies in the future they'll all be
American or Chinese if we stop
subcontracting by European country
companies outside of the EU that's one
thing and yet we're financing irrigation
plants in third countries we're signing
trade agreements with third countries
look in a mirror you're trying to turn
companies into agents of the 2030 agenda
you're playing with the lives and the
money of those outside of Europe
companies should be creating jobs growth
and prosperity but in July in Spain
hopefully we will be following the path
of Sweden Hungary Poland and a new
Europe made up of three nations will
have a Resurgence thank you
thank you very much
next speaker on behalf of the ID is
ladies and gentlemen the idea of
obliging companies to make sure that
their Partners respect the environment
and human rights throughout the supply
chain is very appealing it is in line
with the ambitious goal of making
Capital capitalism more ethical
but of course this burdens company with
the more red tape and so we must take
this path very cautiously before we make
sure we're not going to destabilize
whole swathes of the European economy
yes we have certain safeguards for
example excluding smes that will only
have to have this due diligence
obligation on a voluntary basis
or the fact that this will apply to
non-eu big companies that trade in
Europe but there are environmental
obligations and then there's the issue
of the supply chain that we have to take
into account this isn't just about
direct trade relations all these
uncertainties mean that business won't
have an acceptable legal certainty and
that is why I don't support this text
thank you
on behalf of the left group
is
[Music]
dear colleagues
I'm speaking to you very emotionally
about a major victory against
multinationals impunity a victory for
human rights for the environment where
the multinationals will no longer be
able to undermine it without being held
responsible well before the courts that
is a victory for the hundred thousand
people expropriated by total in Uganda
for the 5 600 workers that died in Qatar
for the World Cup or those that are
being exploited by shine and Zara
outside of Europe it's a victory for all
of those victims who finally can have
access to Justice without the
multinationals hiding behind their
subcontractors or their subsidiaries a
victory it has to be said
dear colleagues that we tore away from
the lobbies the lies to protect the
ridiculous profits they make
to the detriment of workers and the
environment we have fought for years in
Brussels to ensure that these crimes are
no longer unpunished today one for once
here in the European Parliament then the
people power has proven to actually
take Primacy over the interests of money
thank you
thank you very much I now like to pass
the floor
to individual members Mr stefanek
one minute thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen responsible business
making is important not only for job
creation but also as a whole society
through its example many companies
started to follow the principle of a
responsible business making based on
their own decisions I believe that
responsible entrepreneurship cannot be
enforced through Administration or new
rules regulations because we cannot
enforce respect for human rights by
increasing bureaucracy which already is
a huge burden for our smes
legislation should be clearly defining
which areas are truly risky companies
cannot be financially responsible for
damages they do not have any impact on
or replace the role of states the main
basis for Success must be clearly
defined roles responsibilities as well
as the scope of this legislation without
such modifications it'll only become
difficult to implement tool and an
obstacle to responsible business making
rather than its support
oh my God
Mr stefanek
you've got a blue card so I wonder if
you want to answer
is by Madame Oakley
you can take the podium yeah
thank you very much president
is it okay yeah
thank you very much Mr stefanik I listen
to you very carefully
and you say that companies cannot be
held accountable throughout their whole
supply chain but do you agree that
businesses know their supply chains when
it comes to profits when it comes to
raking the money in they can find
the cheapest labor and the cheapest
Factory so they're okay with raking in
the profits and making sure that it
finds its way to them but not when it
comes to Human Rights so why are you
going to vote against a text
thank you for this question I shall vote
against this text because this is uh
um going over and above the original
proposal from the European commission
and if you ask me whether companies know
everything about their
um
Partners
suppliers of course they know a lot
about them but they but cannot cannot be
held responsible for everything their
suppliers do
investors for instance investing in
Europe are telling us that they cannot
simply control every single
um supplier or business partner
that supplies them every single detail
for the product this will just put a
burden in our companies and I believe
based on my personal experience that
responsible business making is really an
honor and those companies that we have
in Europe a large majority of them they
are really proud of being responsible
social responsible but we cannot enforce
this in an administrative way
a responsible business making really has
to come naturally and by putting these
rules and regulations so we are
putting at a disadvantage our companies
especially those small and medium-sized
companies that are the backbone Arab
economy
thank you very much I recall that in
this blue card procedure it is supposed
to be
30 seconds for the question and 30
seconds for the answer try to stick to
the allocated time now I give the
thought to mark belka one minute
thank you very much resident
when
uh Rana plaza building collapsed 10
years ago
a similar burden fell on our European
hearts and Minds
subsiding to the charm of uh chopping
shopping cheaply for clothing made in
Bangladesh we forgot that behind the low
price that we see are human tragedies
children working or devastated
environments
in a normal world we would expect the
customers to know about where they where
the products they buy come from
unfortunately some corporations
including polish ones
are improving the working conditions but
other do agree to slave work by oigor's
or devastating environment that is why
we have to support the introducing of
this directive and a lot of Voters
report because it imposes the obligation
for due diligence on human rights and
work workers rights and Environmental
Protection so the memory of the victims
of the Rana Plaza tragedy obliges us to
do so so I call on all my polish
colleagues to support the draft
developed in the Yuri committee without
any amendments thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
next speaker
one minute
thank you dear colleagues are
smartphones the devices We Carry in our
pockets often contain minerals that
Finance bloody Civil Wars 20 percent of
the global wool production originates
from xinjiang Province where evidence
clearly shows that ugor Force labor
fuels the industry soybeans use the
industrial cattle farming are directly
linked to the destruction of the Amazon
and you know over the last couple of
months I've heard so many colleagues so
many lawmakers and I have to say sorry
but particularly from the right
dismissing these concerns that yes it
happens in distant places this is not
really our business I'm sorry to say but
this is literally our business at its
core the corporate sustainability due
diligence directive focuses on the
footprint our European companies live on
human rights and the environment
wherever they may operate in the world
and we want our companies to be the
Agents of positive change should they
cause harm it is also our responsibility
to hold them accountable here in
European courts
so the European Parliament has made
crucial improvements to the commission's
proposal and it is very important to
stick to them the time for progress is
now thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much next speaker Marie
Tucson one minute
ladies and gentlemen the situation is
straightforward if businesses don't
respect the Paris Accord then we won't
be able to rein in global warming to 1.5
degrees Celsius let us be honest none of
the petrochemicals possible whether any
or uh
uh reps or Toto are on the right path
it's pretty straightforward if
businesses still depend on Plastics or
um forever chemicals then we won't be
able to protect the forests of the world
the Himalayas and other areas from this
pollution that makes our planet toxic so
if we don't manage to make sure that the
economy Works within the limits of our
planets we're continuing to make it
impossible to continue living
on planet Earth we have to adopt the
scsdd because businesses have to respect
the principle the rules and the laws
that have to apply to everyone they have
to assume their Corporate social and
environmental responsibility because the
wrecked lives of people because of
forced labor or the toxic chemicals in
their bodies far away from our borders
are just as important as the lives you
want to protect on European
ask us to protect their lands from the
ravaging projects of a total in Uganda
and that they want a future then the EU
has to act thank you
foreign
I come from a traditional capitalist
school I think that the purpose of
business is to generate profit and not
prove what they have achieved all the
time or to show loyalty to the elites
and its prevailing ideology we speak a
lot about China
but
to be competitive against China we can't
just regulate due diligence as contained
in this report is I think crossing the
line and it will hit hard
on the smes most of all companies that
everyone here in a very hypocritical way
call the backbone of the European
economy Let's Make a Deal now let's show
them that we mean what they say about
them and let's reject this stupid and
dangerous report
thank you very much next speaker this
demanders one minute
thank you
president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen
the CDA
supports the proposal of this point of
departure of corporate sustainability
due diligence because it's part of our
values
and this is uh something that many
colleagues have talked about
establishing a Level Playing Field in
Europe but there's a problem here it's
only a directive it's a directive that
has to be transposed in each member
State you get 27 different systems that
is not a Level Playing Field so would
call on everybody
support Amendment 423 tomorrow that asks
for maximum harmonization
The Point of Departure that we stand
behind wholeheartedly to help all
companies in the EU I'd ask the
commissioner to support that to support
this idea in the trialogs and I hope
everybody will vote to the right way
tomorrow
another point I'd like to mention and
this is kind of last but not least I'd
like to ask the commissioner to confirm
the situation that small companies
the corner
um butcher the football company sorry
the football club around the corner or
the music Club should never fall under
the obligations of this legislation for
reporting
and I think better safe than sorry sorry
surely it should be our mantra
agriculture
oh yeah one minute thank you president
it's taken intense months a very
difficult negotiations to get this far
thank you very much to the reporter for
the work that she's done
she's been very careful there's been
awareness raising campaigns in favor of
corporate
due diligence and all of us need to in
fact remember what happened in Rana
Plaza we don't want to be Hypocrites we
don't want to have shared crocodile
tears
we want to be consistent with the U and
the oecd and their recommendations and
we want to ensure stakeholders are
involved all the way down the line I'm
on the industry committee and I have
heard the concerns that the business
world has been voicing but I would
recall here that with this Provisions we
have said we'll provide more assistance
to smes for their supply for their
supply chains or for the costs of audit
procedures
so as to ensure that they can cope too
so I am sure that I've done my duty in
working on this and that together with
the other colleagues we have come up
with the best answers we can to the
problems facing us I think that European
industry needs to be ready for this
change not only is it timely but it
should in fact also open up new
opportunities for business along new
models new lines for European companies
thank you
thank you very much
Madame Rodriguez Ramos one minute
gracias Presidente thank you very much
voting on the corporate sustainability
due diligence is an unprecedented moment
we have binding obligations and
[Music]
its scope is unprecedented it's a first
around the world today I'd like to ask
all MEPS to vote in favor of this but
against the Amendments uh it is a step
forward it's about honesty and
consistency it's to make sure that what
the values that we say that we support
are in fact something we do support it's
important for the families and their
victims affected by brumadino the Rana
Plaza collabs families who are clamoring
for the truth and Justice and this law
does just that and make sure that this
doesn't happen again please vote in
favor of it because most European
citizens want this more than 76 percent
of European citizens want this please
vote in favor because most European
businesses want this because most
European companies do show due diligence
and we have to make sure that those who
don't will do so we are favor of
Defending human rights and the
environment thank you
one minute
thank you thank you president
commissioner
the sweatshops are still going at Full
Throttle and the victims of these people
are the Invisible Hand to make our cheap
clothing
there are millions of workers in the
fast fashion industry above all women
who are working in very precarious
environments and for a pittance
this sort of corporate sustainability
due diligence law will stop that we'll
at least deal with the Cowboys
this law should make sure that the chain
entire chain will be covered and
monitored
their references to subcontractors and
subsidiaries wherever abuses are carried
out they'll be uncovered we as a as
consumers have a right to make sure that
anything we buy off the rack in a shop
has been produced in a Fair Way ladies
and gentlemen we are very much in favor
of this law because in adopting this we
are actually producing a fair playing
field without competition on the backs
of the workers thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
last speaker Mr Garcia Del Blanco
good evening if you read this
legislation smes are excluded from the
scope and so people that are worried
about this don't have to be and convert
in favor of this with a clear conscience
if companies have got more than 250
employees then they'll be affected not
if they've got less
I I spoke this morning with someone
called Segundo who's been working for
nine years in a multinational and has
been working without any rights for this
company do we really want to carry on
accepting the kind of practices
companies are exercising
child labor I have to admit I think I'm
better than that and I think that most
European citizens are better than that
and I really do think that there's a
tide in the Affairs of men ladies and
gentlemen when we have to listen to our
conscience and so tomorrow please this
time listen to your conscience before
you vote
thank you very much now we come to the
cash TI procedure
please stick to the allocated time one
minute I'll begin with Hannah virkudan
ese
thank you president it is clear that
Enterprise is my second in a responsible
way and each Enterprise must
be in charge of its own actions the aim
here is good but the companies have a
lot of responsibilities since they now
have to estimate how they work and how
all of the value chain works as to the
distribution and all of the parts of the
chain and they must see what the
environmental impacts are as well as the
impacts on human rights this is a large
task we talked about big multinationals
but now the limit is 250 workers bigger
Enterprises than that however these
obligations will also reach out to the
smaller companies since these value
chains include a lot of small companies
in distribution transport and so on and
we must find out the way they work so
this will cause a lot of Burden about
administrative and other and we should
be able to
facilitate these companies position the
financial position also is important we
must estimate that and we must see to it
that this
we must take into consideration that
this influences the companies a lot and
this is not necessarily uh the way that
they should do it
thank you very much
so next speaker Maria Arena
thank you very much commissioner up to
now we knew that the world of business
was against any law that would impose
due diligence so this is an important
step forward if we vote through this law
what are we talking about we're talking
about total energy with the e-cop
project that destroys the climate and
there are others such as Nike that is
making money out of forced laborers
agenda that exports highly toxic
substances in Peru seat leading to
deforestation in Southeast Asia now
voluntary
rules do not work they just lead to the
kind of environmental disasters and
human disasters that we're talking about
today so this law has to help us prevent
to minimize but also to remediate
through Justice we're talking about a
virtuous circle for our businesses we
have to make sure that our companies
carry out positive change and that don't
Aid and abet all these human rights
violations and environmental rules
violations thank you
thank you very much next speaker now
Marty galley
[Music]
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
incredibly often I here on the streets
um on the squares well what's this got
to do with us if in Bangladesh some
building collapses or what's it got to
do with us if in Brazil a dam collapses
or what's it to do with us if
Uganda people are dispossessed surely
the people in those countries should
worry about that these are the people
who have to tell listen we are living in
a globalized world we have to assume
responsibility as to what our companies
do around the world and it's not
it's not always pretty
so we now have a huge opportunity to
make sure that the rules that we are
applying to our companies in the EU on
human rights that they don't just apply
here in the EU that they naturally apply
outside the EU and that strengthens
European companies we should be clear
about that it prevents exploitation and
I recall on all of you to support this
proposal thank you thank you thank you
very much
the next speaker is Mr Aslam demerel
thank you very much president 2012
259 people died in a Pakistani textile
Factory in a fire
they were producing for the the German
textile
company kick and then the victims took
kick to the court and it the case was
thrown out
that is a mockery and kicks is not the
only example of this
in around the world in African Asia and
Latin America the multinational
companies Western companies European
companies are exploiting people and
exploiting nature brutally
they
abuse rules on protecting workers Etc
and they don't bat an eyelid simply
because they have no obligation to Bear
accountability so what happens
well let's uh let's have this voluntary
approach let us coddle these people so
that they do what they ought to do Mr
Vos no it's no longer the time to do
that let us put our arms around and
coddle the workers let's coddle the
trade unions the people who are being
abused the people whose rights are being
trampled underfoot so this directive is
not a revolution it is the minimum that
needs to be done
and it is in fact workers who generate
Prosperity as well not just the
companies and have a call on the
conservative colleagues to support this
directive and not to work against the
interests of the trade unions our next
one is Madame Guri
dear colleagues this proposal is another
nail in the coffin of European
competitiveness it gives a lot of power
to ngos
to Blackmail the companies
and companies are held responsible they
need to police one another instead of
creating employment and jobs I'm asking
the commission how can you achieve 25
percent reduction in reporting and where
is the famous
SME filter meaning that the commission
never proposes anything that is bad for
the smes last year almost 150 new
proposals came to light that were
damaging and energy prices inflation all
these difficult situation makes life
very tough for smes
companies are able to be fair without
rules first on them please Epp and
liberals wake up and do not vote for
this text tomorrow
Gonzalez
thank you very much president
we have a responsibility as Europeans
because of our reach and this law
on due diligence together with our trade
policy will help us to avoid corruption
in Global Supply chains and in business
relations but it's also important that
we cover smes too and that this
legislation should cover all kinds of
companies public and private we need
administrative and civil and criminal
liability to be covered we are now going
to fight in trilog to ensure that this
agreement is properly implemented and
applied and is included in the mecca
share agreement for example
this will keep us in the Forefront of
Human Rights struggles and
sustainability struggles throughout the
world please don't support the
Amendments please support the original
text which has been agreed upon by all
of the Committees together thank you
the directive is there to protect
monopolies the EU is helping business
circles and is making sure that it
doesn't have to pay for the fact that it
is striving for maximum profits making
life a misery for its workers it's all
about pillaging the environment the
capitalists stayed backed by the
directive means that it's the businesses
that will check themselves will monitor
themselves how can that be
they will be holding themselves
accountable or not and they will even be
able to get some kind of certificate
showing their respect human rights to be
able to show that they have an edge over
their competitors and that they are
better the directive says that it's the
business directors that are responsible
for auditing their own these I mean
you're having a song in Greece it's only
the workers and the people that can do
something about this and give an answer
to you ensuring that it's either their
prophets or our lives and they can only
do so by voting for a stronger Communist
party our colleague Maria Manuel lighter
Marcus
we had a bikini
when I was small in the days of my
grandparents there was a black polluted
river near us that we didn't even dare
touch
now
everything was in fact excused because
of the companies that were providing
jobs for the region now things have
changed we know that many companies are
actively working for sustainability and
that our citizens actually very much
value that this directive is going to
ensure that we do better in the future
so that we don't have to always provide
remedies for things that have been
destroyed so that in fact we can don't
carry on accepting intolerable practices
this is something that we want for the
future for any future thank you
that brings a catch the eye procedure to
a close I'd now like to give the floor
to commissioner randers
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
first of all I'd like to thank you very
much for all your comments and remarks
you know that we have an ambitious
agenda on sustainability
this initiative was unveiled seven years
after the Rana Plaza tragedy and through
this initiative we'll be able to
implement our social commitments
environmental commitments and human
right commitments through corporate
governance the European commission has
followed both an ambitious approach and
a proportionate one in its proposal for
our directive
smes are excluded
yeah
I'm very happy to see that we I have a
broad broad support in this parliament
in order to avoid fragmentation through
different National legislation and in
order to have a fairer and more
sustainable economy
of course I'll be thrilled to embark on
the trials before the summer if possible
as you know this firewall this file is
one of the key priorities
during my term and I can assure you that
I'm very committed to this going through
thank you very much
thank you colleagues for this debate
thank you to all those who participated
and it's great to see the support
expressed by so many colleagues here
today and I hope that this backing will
transform into a substantial majority
tomorrow
at the same time let me address some of
the criticism expressed here today I
hear that due diligence will affect
Europe's competitiveness but the very
core of this law is a Level Playing
Field between EU and non-eu companies
I've heard also that this would be a
disproportionate burden for companies
but that overlooks the reality of what
we're proposing here we don't ask
companies to go and fight every problem
on this planet we allow them to
prioritize actions that are relevant to
them and to the risks that they face
we're aware of the importance of
Industry collaboration in different
sectors and we're preventing heavy
contractual obligations for smes
I'd like to reassure people that there's
the local
uh butcher or the football club unless
it is uh registered as having 250
employees and having a turnover of 40
million euros it'll be free of problems
23 not only are companies able to rise
to the challenge of due diligence in the
future they are already doing it Aldi
Ikea Unilever Asos Mars Erickson those
are just some of the companies calling
for human rights and environmental
standards that give more clarity on what
we mean by responsible business they are
joined by prominent trade associations
in the financial pharmaceutical and
Technology sectors to name a few
those who are now seeking to frustrate
this law are siding with a minority of
political and Commercial interests and
they are electioneering
to my colleagues who need to vote
tomorrow I want to say if you're on the
side of millions of citizens who want to
see change as well as the businesses and
civil society that are pleading for that
if you're on the side of responsibility
and a Europe fit to lead on the big
questions of our time then show that
tomorrow reject the Amendments back this
compromise and let us go to trialogs and
last but definitely not least I want to
very well warmly thank the commissioner
for his leadership in this all of my
colleagues who have worked so
constructively with me on this and have
been so involved and my own team Matthew
Hogarth and Helen biag whose very last
working day in the European Parliament
is tomorrow and without whose help this
would not have been possible so thank
you so much to all
thank you
[Applause]
that concludes this debate the vote will
take place tomorrow
that brings us on to the next item on
our agenda
Council commission statements
on breaches of the rule of law and
fundamental rights in Hungary and Frozen
EU funds
and on behalf of the council I'd like to
ask Mr pieter culgreen to take the floor
foreign
[Music]